[Musique]
les collègues de fender scolaires
permettent après au public on reçoit
tout au long de l'année au moment de la
rentrée de pouvoir quand même répondre
aux besoins de leurs enfants
du coup toutes n'ont pas forcément les
moyens de pouvoir
s'acheter les matériels nécessaires pour
la rentrée malgré les aides petit puis à
voir il ya quand même pas mal de choses
à acheter
et quand elles ont plusieurs et par le
coût s'accroît davantage avec plusieurs
enfants donc du coup c'est pour pouvoir
soutenir les différentes familles qu'on
a condamné
[Musique]
et là effectivement plus de femmes il a
du mal à la corrida en fait nous ça
nous a fait accueillir plus de public et
des publics un peu différent aussi comme
les étudiants les gens du voyage et
c'est vrai que même les familles en
hôtel social on l'est on l'est toujours
davantage depuis l'art depuis la crise
sanitaire et céret du coup main comme
ont touché plus de public et maya plus
de demandes en fait après de la poule
aux coûts en termes de matty de produits
scolaires
on peut donner de plus de diverses
produits basiques ça va des stylos
cahiers après c'est avec les produits
qui coûtent un peu plus cher comme les
cartables les calculatrices les mêmes
tout ce qui est con pas aux
équipes de traçage c'est les produits
qui sont un peu plus un peu plus cher et
qui du coup sont les produits que on
peut proposer davantage mais
eksi et plombe un peu le budget des
aides des familles qu'on reçoit donc
cessé sur le prix du lait sont toujours
appréciés